[Музика]
привіт знову сьогодні Оксана Іваненко
знову з вами під час нашої онлайн-школи.
Сьогодні зі мною є особливий гість, це Mr.  Пол ло, він мій
колега і старий друг привіт Пол,
привіт, я дуже радий працювати з тобою
сьогодні тієї ж осені, тому сьогодні ми
завершуємо нашу тему, яка називається
фестивалі та урочистості 7 мс над
кладовищем книга кімоно сказала qivana das
Vita Україна Аніта  Пасео Маседо, і
це наш останній клас, Дженна, вона була
крихітною гіркою, тому ми почнемо з гри
сьогодні,
о, вони люблять грати в ігри, я люблю
грати в ігри, тому сьогодні я пропоную
почати з асоціаційної гри Сухані
зі спогадами, яка називалася суспільством,
тому  тут у нас є слово фестивалі внизу,
і для кожної букви нам потрібно починати
слово, яке ми асоціюємо зі
святом чи фестивалем в Україні
чи Великобританії добре, у вас є якісь
ідеї, а це може бути однією з моїх
улюблених речей їжа добре  згоден з
тобою добре, якщо ти не проти, я виберу це,
і це буде Великдень, тому що цього
року на Великдень у нас було дивовижне полювання з моїм
маленьким сином.
з літерою S зараз хто в основному
є підказкою, чи можу я отримати допомогу,
чи це фестиваль, який
пов'язаний із зеленим кольором, багато зеленого
скрізь вул.  День Святого Патрика
абсолютно добре, і наша наступна буква C
хм, це може бути складно,
можливо, чому б нам не вибрати День
подяки так мм-хм, але я впевнений, що я
буду для вас
викликом О, виклик, чи можу я мати іншу підказку,
будь ласка, Оксана  добре, подумай про
те, що багато людей люблять його, він холодний і
солодкий, і ми особливо любимо їсти його
влітку з морозивом так, до речі, який
твій улюблений смак льоду
має бути фісташковий, добре, я теж люблю це,
і так, ти знаєш  Я
дуже довго думав
про букву V і вирішив
, що зроблю трюк, і це буде
дуже смішно,
чому б не написати, якщо ви не можете придумати
слово, яке починається на v чому чому don  't it
be very funny
then letter ate a Я не дуже розумний
сьогодні я не мав уявлення, ви також знаєте,
яким словом ви опишете
чудовий фестиваль або чудовий
досвід, у вас є дивовижні так, це
правда  так це ще один синонім
до слова велике добре чудо  ful
дивовижна добре літера L то чому б вам не
включити слово lock
look oh yeah, удача, звичайно, всім
потрібна удача
абсолютно, і добре, я залишу це для
вас вул.  День святого Валентина тепер усі знають,
що я не романтик, це тому, що ти
завжди думаєш про їжу, ти знаєш
не більший, але шлях до серця чоловіка –
це вільний самміт,
добре вул.  Валентина добре, хлопці, і тепер
ви бачите, що дуже легко потренувати
свій словниковий запас і працювати зі словами,
і робити це весело,
тож давайте розпочнемо та перейдемо далі після
того, як пригадаємо дев’яті слова
про фестивалі, на які ми збираємося рухатися
до заходів, які ми виконуємо під час різних
свят, я знаю, що ви
вже вивчили їх із paniolo Napa Tirico,
але сьогодні ми збираємося переглянути
їх, тому Папа допоможе мені з цими
фразами, тому причини нам подобається
фестиваль, але перш ніж ми розпочнемо, що таке
причини, чому тобі подобається Фестер, будь-який
фестиваль, так мій улюблений фестиваль, але
чому тобі подобаються пір'я взагалі,
тому що вони сказали, що коли люди можуть
спілкуватися, ти знаєш, зустрічаєшся з їхніми
друзями і загалом отримуєш багато
насолоди і будьш дуже щасливий і веселий,
добре, так  тепер давайте подивимося
на фрази, що ми робимо під час
свят, щоб ми могли зробити щось
зі свічками та загадати бажання що
це те, що ми робимо на дні народження б  але зараз
я такий старий, що на торті не вистачає місця
для всіх свічок, я не
вірю, але я помітив одну, коли
ви точно знаєте хлопців, тому я сподіваюся, що ви
були першими, а потім містером.  Павло і ви
правильно вгадали слово, так що це
правильно задуйте свічки, і що ми робимо
з прикрасами навколо наших будинків і
навколо міст на вулицях, які ми
поставили точно правильно, ми ставимо
прикраси, у нас є ця традиція
ставити  прикраси для фестивалів так,
ми робимо особливо на Різдво на
Різдво, у Великобританії це як змагання,
який будинок має найбільше вогнів
на вулиці чи за межами будинку, і
є будинок, відомий будинок у місті
неподалік від мене,
це як на телебаченні  весь час я
не знаю, скільки там лампочок
, можливо, мільйони,
рахунки за електроенергію мають бути величезними, так,
це особливий e на Різдво
багато вогнів, чи отримують вони якісь винагороди я
не знаю, вдячність, дякую,
багато реклами  по телевізору завжди телекамери
знімають деякі будинки, у яких багато
світла так мм-хм добре, тоді люди
щось роблять під час фестивалів зі
своєю родиною та друзями святкуємо так,
ми святкуємо фестивалі та  e
різні події, які пов'язані з
нашим святковим життям наступний ми віримо,
деякі речі ой, зроби щось нам
удачу, так що деякі речі приносять нам удачу
точно правильно чи знаєте ви, що в
Україні чорний капелюх приносить вам
нещастя, а не удачу я  знав, що
в деяких країнах удача, деякі
країни – це невезіння, і згідно
з традиціями Великобританії, що таке речі,
які речі приносять вам
удачу, удачу я знаю багато речей,
які приносять вам нещастя, але удача
буде  чотирилистий конюшина це був
дивний з моєї школи, але я не
впевнений, чи це правда, але якщо ви бачили
похоронне майно, як хтось,
на жаль, їхав на
цвинтар на чорних машинах, якщо відразу
після того, як ви побачили чорні машини, ви потім
побачили  чотирилапа тварина виглядає як
кіт чи собака на вулиці,
це означає, що твоя удача зміниться
на те хороше, що цікаво. Я чув у тій
школі, тому я не знаю, чи це
історія про те, що це правда, я знаю, що
в Україні в нас є традиція, коли
ти бачиш це шлюбний візок
весільний візок
і торкаєшся грошей, це означає, що у
тебе багато грошей у майбутньому, тому я
перевірив це кілька разів, але все одно ти
бачите, що мені потрібно, мені потрібно  ходіть на роботу, тому поки що немає
вітрильника, немає особистого літака, але
також достатньо відомої
весільної традиції, яка,
можливо, така ж удача в Україні, як і у Великобританії, тому,
коли наречена вийшла заміж, вона заморозила
свій букет через плече, і яку
самка спіймає  це вони
наступні одружуються, це удача
так, я маю на увазі, ти чистиш, так, те саме
і зі мною була ще одна весела ситуація
, коли жінка під час весілля мого
близького друга стояла так
і книжковий кіт впав прямо в неї  зброї
та вгадай, за якого Павла ти одружишся наступного
тижня
абсолютно так, це було справді
несподівано для нас все добре,
давайте йти далі, тоді багато хто з нас щось зробить
із властивостями вечірок
передостаннє, це так круто два різницю  орендувати
традиції ми вже мали святкувати,
так, ми вже святкували,
але що ми робимо з традиціями,
я сьогодні поганий учень, тому насправді вони
дотримуються дотримуйтеся так, вони дотримуються
традицій, коли ми дотримуємося традицій,
ми робимо те саме щоразу  рік у
особливий день, і останній – діти
люблять робити щось із подарунками,
а дорослі також робимо добре, це
може бути відкрито приймати так, так, і те, що
це інтимне, це слово відкрите, тому що наші
діти дуже розумні та  слово
відкрити для них занадто легко. О, в такому
випадку його було б розгорнуто, так
, це розгорнуто, тепер давайте подивимося,
чи пан.  Пол був правий чи ні,
ось речення з відповідями, і я
впевнений, що ви всі правильно їх дали,
а тепер ми переходимо до наступного
етапу уроку, тож наше наступне завдання –
розібрати цю хмару слів.  подивіться,
які слова
дивіться тут і словосполучення, з чим вони
пов'язані я бачу їжу
відразу я бачу їжу чому ти
зараз голодний я завжди голодний
це все
добре, тому мені потрібно я думаю, що мені потрібно тебе нагодувати
правильний обід так так після вашої
важкої роботи під час сьогоднішнього уроку добре,
так що ви хочете, щоб я вибрав традицію,
яку я можу бачити для своїх слів, так,
так, всі ці слова пов'язані
з деякими святкуваннями, про які ми розповідали
з вами та з paniolo та
під час наших онлайн-занять, тож Кріс
Різдво смажив індичку, чому він просто
смажив індичку на Різдво Цікаво,
бо це різдвяна традиція у
Великобританії їсти індичку 25 грудня
серйозно насправді я починаю ще одне
святкувати  Дякую  iving так, я
подумав про День подяки правильно, добре
О, а як щодо шоколадних яєць, це була
б Великдень для пошуку скарбів правильно,
і все це
було б правильно  Я боюся, що наші
діти ще не знають святкування,
тож це більш загальні фестивальні паради,
частування з барвистими костюмами та
танцювальними та співаючими вуличними декораціями
, до речі, у Бразилії є відомий один
– нечутний карне
, це правда, Greenleaf, я б хотів  сказав
якийсь День Патріка, очевидно, що у нас
вже був такий, тож це
означає, що у нас є кілька предметів для одного
святкування, ви кажете так, так, добре, а як
щодо сімейної вечері, це може бути
знову День подяки або Різдво
, і Ірландія Ірландія
буде трохи  Патріка так, це правда,
тому, хлопці, зараз ми
поглянемо на таблицю, де пан.  Пол допоміг
нам розділити всі
слова на групи, тому я сподіваюся, що ви зробили
це з нами і зробили це правильно, тому
ви були абсолютно правильні для
Різдва, у нас є прикраси, Санта
і Різдвяна ялинка та День подяки,
це сімейний пиріг із смаженою
індичкою  табір також йти на
Різдво правильно так, можливо, не гарбузовий
пиріг, але так, і сімейна вечеря напевно
Пасхальний заєць шоколадні яйця весна
і карнавал давайте барвисті костюми
співати вниз співати танцювальні паради і
вул.  День Святого Патрика проводиться в Ірландії,
тому символом є зелене листя, яке
називається те, що трилистник є
національною квіткою або емблемою Ірландії. Я
Sol — це конюшина
з конюшини.  День Патріка праворуч від
цієї маленької людини лепрекона так так,
так, добре, і знаменита чорна борода
двоє маленьких дітей не можуть його пити
так і, нарешті, капелюх, який також
присвячений цьому святу, добре,
зараз, будь ласка, запам'ятайте назви цих
свят, щоб ми  мають Різдво
Подяки Великодній карнавал і вул.
Святого Патрика вони нам знадобляться для
наступного завдання,
тому, власне, що станеться далі, ми бачимо
нотатки від різних дітей, де вони
описують, який тип урочистостей їм
подобається найбільше, і здогадаємося, що нам
тут потрібно зробити, це означає, що нам потрібно їх прочитати
спочатку правильно, а потім
пам’ятайте про наші святкування та фестивалі, нам
потрібно вгадати, який може бути їхнім
улюбленим фестивалем, добре, так
що почнеш, будь ласка, добре, так що це від
Софі 11 років Я відчуваю себе щасливим, коли ми
дотримуємося різних сімейних традицій, як-от
грати в ігри чи шукати речі на
вулиці
, як ви думаєте, хлопці, який може бути
її улюблений фестиваль, ви вже
здогадалися, так, я здогадався, що це добре
що вони роблять на вулиці, а також грають в
сімейні ігри, тож я прочитаю від
Кейт, якій 10 років, вона пише, що
вона любить сімейні посиденьки, коли вони
можуть проводити час вдома, готувати  смачно поїсти
та насолоджуватися товариством один одного, ви знаєте,
я серйозно подвійний,
тому що це можуть бути справжні фестивалі,
залежать від того, звідки Кейт, якщо
Кейт зі Сполучених Штатів, це
буде День подяки, якщо вона з
Великобританії, це буде Різдво  правильно,
давайте нагадаємо нашим молодим студентам, що
Сполучене Королівство, це Великобританія,
а Сполучені Штати, це Америка
декорацій, де люди в барвистих
костюмах співають і танцюють разом, що
може бути вул.  день патріка, я думаю, чи
є у вас інший карнавал чи карнавал,
кожен карнавал так, має бути добре,
так що ви зібралися з нами, це було
легко, а тепер пан.  опитування, чи розкажете ви
нам про свій улюблений фестиваль,
який це мій улюблений фестиваль,
можливо, це буде листопад,
листопад п’ятий, це фестиваль
спеціально для Сполученого Королівства, і
це досить історичне, ми дізнаємося про це в
історії, і це було далеко від 1605 року в
1605 році  дуже милий чоловік на ім'я Гай Фокс
вирішив, що хоче підірвати частину
і вбити Джеймса першого, який був
королем, оскільки таксі з королем у той час,
коли Гай Фокс був католиком, і
йому не подобалося, як попередній
монарх королева Єлизавета перша
була не дуже приємна до католиків, а
Джеймс перший ввів ще більше правил
проти католиків, тому хлопці-факи намагалися
підірвати парламент, але напередодні його схопили
з усім порохом
під парламентом у підвалі,
і він був  спіймали, і вони все це зупинили,
тому Джеймс Перший сказав, що
вся країна повинна святкувати
5 листопада, коли вони знайшли цього чоловіка, і
ми повинні святкувати, влаштувавши велике
багаття в нашому саду  ens і ми спалюємо
опудало, як манекен Гая Фокса, і ми
вибиваємо тисячі феєрверків, і ми
їмо хот-доги та картоплю з жаке, так що
ніби дуже холодно
всіх зігріло багаття, яке
чудове, і що ви будете робити на цьому
святі?  є якісь прогнози,
я знову буду їсти багато їжі, добре,
тож ви влаштуєте феєрверки так, у нас є
феєрверки, але, звичайно, батькам
подобається, що феєрверк був досить небезпечним
для маленьких дітей, а також зараз є
багато державних виставок,
де вони наймають  парк люди стоять
позаду паркану, а уряд чи
місцеве місто, яке вони мають, як великий груповий
феєрверк, щоб людям не доводилося
випускати феєрверки у своїх садах,
тому що у ваших садах занадто близько до
будинку небезпечно і це дуже лякає
домашніх тварин собак і котів, тож у нас зараз немає великих
групових виставок, це дивовижно, я
думаю, що це величезне шоу для всіх,
так, а тепер ми переходимо
до невеликого перегляду граматичного часу
ion guys так, як ви чули Mr.  Павло
висловив свої надії та прогнози
щодо майбутнього святкування
ночі багаття, яка буде
5 листопада 5 листопада, право, щоб
просто запам'ятати для наших студентів дату,
і тому, коли ми говоримо про подібні
дії, коли ми висловлюємо нашу надію, ми  надія,
що щось станеться, повірте в
це, і коли ми думаємо, що щось
станеться інакше або так, як ми
думаємо про те, що ми щойно називали
передбаченнями, ми використовуємо волю, яка зазвичай
скорочується до «Ола, давайте поглянемо
на пояснення, тому тут  у нашому
поясненні ви бачите
силует особи, це означає
виконавця дії, тому щоразу, коли ви бачите
срібло, це означає людину, яка виконує цю
дію, потім ми додаємо will, а
потім дієслово, яке є словом дії,
як у  приклад, який ви бачите, буде організована
величезна вечірка на день народження моєї мами,
і негативне, будь ласка, пам'ятайте, чи ми
говоримо не буде англійською мовою, ми
не робимо, ми не робимо, ми говоримо не буде мм-хм, і
ви знаєте, що я  чув, що іноді діти
плутають це з бажанням ні, ні, я хочу їсти,
ти не даси мені їсти так, тож ви
бачите, що інша вимова,
коли ви чогось хочете, це означає, що
вам потрібно це зробити правильно, наприклад, я
хочу свій ноутбук, тому що я  Я роблю
презентацію або Mr.  Пол хоче їсти,
тому що він голодний, але не хоче з oh
it's it mean will not that it is not that it is the
negative form of the future time so a
person won't plus діє дієслова та
приклад mr.  Пол, ми всі плюс дієслово
like for questions,
чи допоможе дитина нам розклеїти прикраси
мм-хм, правильно, тож, коли
ми ставимо запитання, які ми ставимо, буде на першому місці
в реченні, а зараз останнє
вправа нашого класу, тому я  Я впевнений, що
ви дуже втомилися
через купу інформації,
яку ви отримали сьогодні, але я обіцяю, що
це остання, тому тут нам потрібно вставити
правильну форму дієслова will у
запропоноване речення номер один, яке
ви часто зустрічаєте  хороших людей на шкільній
вечірці, що ви думаєте, Mr.  Пол,
це передбачення, тому ви будете
абсолютно наступним, оскільки ми бачимо
знак питання в кінці речення,
це означає, що ми повинні почати наше
речення з форми, чи буде форма запитання,
щоб це було, чи чорна кішка принесе
добро  удачі чи невезіння у вашій
країні наступного, що моя бабуся задуває
100 свічок на свій день народження цього року
, це абсолютно багато свічок на торті,
і це велика надія, і
ми відпускаємо феєрверк, тому що зараз занадто
пізно,
тому я думаю  нам потрібно поставити, можливо, це може
бути 6 листопада і ми запускаємо
феєрверк 5 листопада, тому, можливо, ми
не будемо випускати феєрверк так,
і останній, але не останній, я
сподіваюся, що ми знайдемо багато подарунків під
Різдво  дерево о, це передбачення, тому
ми будемо так, абсолютно так, ось наші
відповіді, все правильно, тому на
даний момент ми закінчили з темою
фестивалів і свят, а поки
ми попрощаємося з вами до побачення і
дякую, axalta до побачення  e і дякую за те, що ви
приєдналися до мене під час цього уроку. Я сподіваюся,
що скоро побачу вас тут знову, я сподіваюся, що теж
добре, до побачення всім, хто був Pontiacs
Donna та Mr.  поло разом з вами
під час наших онлайн-занять англійською мовою
[Музика]
ви